sort the expressions according to their
values you can put any number of cards
in a category or leave a category empty
and so we have this diagram right over
here now we have these cards that have
these expressions and we're supposed to
we're supposed to sort these into
different buckets so we're trying to say
well what is the length of segment AC
over the set length of segment BC equal
to which of these expressions is it
equal to and then we should drag it into
the appropriate appropriate buckets so
to figure these out I've actually
already redrawn this problem on my
little on my on my little I guess you
call it scratch pad or blackboard
whatever you want to call it this right
over here is that same diagram blown up
a little bit here are the expressions
that we need to drag into things and
here's are the buckets that we need to
see which of these expressions are equal
to which of these expressions so let's
first look at this the length of segment
AC over the length of segment BC so
let's think about what AC is the length
of segment AC AC is this right over here
so it's this length this length right
over here in purple over the length of
segment BC over this length right over
here so the ratio is the ratio of the
lengths of two sides of a right triangle
this is clearly this is clearly a right
triangle triangle a B C and I could
color that in just so you know what
triangle I'm talking about triangle ABC
is this entire this entire triangle that
we could focus on so you could imagine
that it's reasonable that the ratio of
two sides of a right triangle are going
to be the sine of one of its angles and
they give us one of the angles right
over here
they give us they give us this angle
right over here you say well no they
just mark that angle but notice one arc
is here one arc is here so anywhere we
see only one arc that's going to be 30
degrees so this is 30 degrees as well
you have two arcs here that's 41 degrees
two arcs here this is going to be
congruent to that this over here is
going to be 41 degrees this is three
arcs they don't tell us how many how
many degrees that is but this angle with
the three arcs is congruent to this
angle with the three rocks right over
there
so anyway this yellow triangle triangle
ABC
we know this the measure of this angle
is 30 degrees and then they give us
these two sides so how did these sides
late to this 30-degree angle well side
AC is adjacent to it it's literally it's
one of the sides of the angle that is
not the hypotenuse so let me write that
down
this is adjacent adjacent and what is BC
well BC is the hypotenuse of this right
triangle it's the side opposite the 90
degrees so this is the hypotenuse so
some trig function as when applied to 30
degrees is equal to the adjacent side
over the hypotenuse
let's write down sohcahtoa just to
remind ourselves so so Chi Toa sine of
an angle is opposite over hypotenuse
cosine of an exit angle is adjacent over
hypotenuse so cosine let's write this
down cosine of 30 degrees is going to be
equal to the length of the edge a of the
length of the adjacent side so that is
AC AC over the length of the hypotenuse
which is equal to BC so this right over
here is the same thing this is the same
thing as the cosine of 30 degrees so
let's drag it in there this is equal to
the cosine of 30 degrees now let's look
at the next one cosine of angle Dec
cosine of angle Dec where is Dec so de c
d e C so that's this angle right over
here I'll put four arcs here so we don't
get it confused so this is angle Dec so
what is the cosine of Dec well once
again cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
so cosine of angle Dec the adjacent side
to this well that's this right over here
you might say well isn't this side
adjacent well that side side de that is
the actual hypotenuse so that's not
going to be the adjacent side so the
adjacent side is e the adjacent side is
I could call it EC it's the length of
segment EC and then the hypotenuse the
hypotenuse is this right over here is
the length of the hypotenuse the
hypotenuse is side de or
edie however you want to call it and so
the length of it is we could just write
it as de now what is this also equal to
we don't see this choice over here we
don't have the ratio EC over de is one
of these choices here but what we do
have is one of we do get one of the
angles here they give us this 41 degrees
and the greater of this green side over
the length of this green side or this
orange side what would that be in terms
of if we want to apply a trig function
to this angle well relative to this
angle the green side is the opposite
side and the orange side is still the
hypotenuse so relative to 41 degrees so
let's write this down
it relative to 41 degrees this ratio is
the opposite over the hypotenuse it's
the cosine of this angle but it's the
sine of this angle right over here sine
is opposite over hypotenuse so this is
equal to the sine of this angle right
over here it's equal to the sine of 41
degrees so that is this one right over
here the sine of 41 degrees so let's
let's drag that into the appropriate
bucket so let's let's sine of 41 degrees
is the same thing as the cosine of angle
Dec I only have two left so now we have
to figure out what the sine of angle CDA
is so let's see where C da si da is this
entire angle it's this entire angle
right over here so I could put a bunch
of arcs here if I want just to show that
it's different than all the other ones
so that's that angle right over there so
now we're really dealing with this
larger right triangle let me highlight
that in some let me highlight it in this
pink color so we're now dealing with
this larger this larger right triangle
right over here we care about the sine
of this whole thing remember sine is
opposite over hypotenuse sine is
opposite over hypotenuse so the opposite
the opposite side is going to be is
going to be C side C a so this is going
to be equal to the length of
see a over the hypotenuse which is AD
over a D so that is going to be that is
over a D now once again we don't see
that as a choice here but maybe we can
express this ratio maybe this ratio is a
trig function applied to one of the
other angles and they give us one of the
angles they give us this angle right
over here I guess we could call this
angle DAC
this is 30 degrees so relative to this
angle what two sides are we taking the
ratio of we're taking now the ratio of
relative to this angle the adjacent side
over the hypotenuse so this is the
adjacent side over the hypotenuse what
deals with adjacent over hypotenuse well
cosine so this is equal to the cosine of
this angle so this is equal to cosine of
30 degrees sine of CDA is equal to the
cosine of this angle right over here so
this this one is equal to this right
over here so let me let me drag that in
so this one is equal to so you can see
that I just dragged it in equal to that
and now we have one left we have one
left homestretch we should be getting
excited
AE / EB AE let me use this color length
of segment AE that's this length right
over here let me make that stand out
more let me do it in this red this this
color right over here that's the length
of segment AE over length of segment e B
over length of segment EB this is EB
right over here this is e B so now we
are focused on we're focused on this
triangle this right triangle right over
here well we know the measure of this
angle over here we have double arcs we
have double arcs right over right over
here and they say this is 41 degrees so
we have double marks over here then this
is also going to be 41 degrees so
relative to this angle what ratio is
this
is the opposite over over the hypotenuse
opposite over the hypotenuse this right
over here is going to be sine of that
angle sine of 41 degrees so it's equal
to this first one right over there so
let's let's drag it so this is going to
be equal to sine of 41 degrees so none
of the ones actually ended up being
equal to the tangent of 41 degrees now
let's see if we actually got this right
I hope I did we did